Et si on était bientôt capables grâce à
l’intelligence artificielle, de reconstituer
la personnalité des morts ? Non, vous n’êtes
pas dans un épisode de Black Mirror, mais
bien sur une chaîne de vulgarisation scientifique.
Parler avec César, beaucoup d’historiens
en rêvent, et ce n’est pas forcément inenvisageable…
Bienvenue dans l’ère de la “nécromancie
digitale” !
Mais d’abord, avant de ranimer
nos ancêtres, qui roupillent tranquilles
dans leurs sarcophages, laissez-moi vous présenter
VOTRE future couchette : le matelas hybride
de la marque Emma. Emma sponsorise la vidéo
du jour en vous proposant de belles remises
sur les produits de literie…en ce moment
il y a des summer sales jusqu'au
19 juillet. il y a jusqu'à -50% sur le site
et avec ce code vous avez 10% additionnels.
La marque m’a envoyé le matelas hybride
pour que je teste avant de vous en parler
et alors…bonheur. J’ai eu des belles sciatiques
quand j’étais archéo et alors la literie
c’est tout un programme chez moi. Et ici
vous avez un soutien ferme mais avec une bouche
couche bien moelleuse en accueil (oui les
termes techniques je gère, je suis calée.
Il arrive roulé sous vide, il suffit de couper
et de le laisser tranquillement se déplier,
la livraison est hyper rapide. Si vous hésitez
à acheter un matelas en ligne sachez que
ce matelas hybride a reçu le prix UFC Que
Choisir 2021 et que l’autre proposé sur
le site est tout simplement la meilleure vente
en France depuis 2 ans. Vous avez une garantie
de 10 ans, livraison et les retours sont gratuits
et même une période d’essai donc pas de
risques ! Je vous redonne le code pour profiter
de 10% additionnels aux réductions du site.
Et on enchaîne avec la vidéo.
Revenons à nos moutons électriques. Les
archéologues doivent très souvent faire
appel à leur mémoire. Ils apprennent par
cœur des typologies pour connaître la forme
des objets, savoir identifier les poteries,
les silex taillés ou les inscriptions au
premier coup d'œil et gagner du temps sur
le terrain. Mais depuis quelques temps, les
archéologues font appel à de nouveaux outils
pour assister leur mémoire. Certains logiciels
font aujourd’hui un travail extraordinaire
pour compléter l’analyse des chercheurs,
voire pour restituer ce qui n’existe plus,
on va en parler.
En réalité, depuis son origine, l’archéologie
s’est toujours intéressée aux nouvelles
technologies. Pour trouver davantage de vestiges
ou pour livrer des interprétations plus précises,
les archéologues se sont aidés des microscopes
les plus performants, de sonars magnétiques
dernier cri ou de robots sous-marins ultra
perfectionnés. On a d’ailleurs parlé dans
des vidéos plus anciennes de plusieurs de
ces innovations, comme le LIDAR ou la tomographie
qui donnent des résultats spectaculaires.
Aujourd’hui je voudrais faire le point sur
l’une des dernières techniques dont se
sont emparés les archéologues, l’intelligence
artificielle.
Mais avant de voir les applications possibles
pour l’archéologie, il faut expliquer rapidement
le principe de cette méthode, ce qu’on
appelle le « deep-learning ». Bon mais,
étant donné que ce n’est pas mon domaine
de prédilection et que je m’intéresse
surtout aux applications pour trouver des
vieilleries, on ne va pas rentrer dans tous
les détails informatiques, vous l’aurez
compris.
Le « deep-learning », appelé en français
« apprentissage profond », a émergé depuis
une dizaine d’années. Ça consiste à faire
analyser à un programme informatique des
données de manière autonome. Cela est rendu
possible grâce à une architecture complexe
de réseaux de neurones virtuels qu’on appelle
Convolution Neuronal Network (CNN). Inspirés
du fonctionnement du cerveau humain, ils permettent
de faire passer l’information à travers
différentes couches de neurones et de gagner
au fur et à mesure en précision. Voilà
pour la théorie, je vous rassure, il y a
très peu de personnes qui maîtrisent les
détails de cette technologie, nous on veut
simplement comprendre le principe.
Les différentes couches de neurones artificiels
réagissent à différents types d’informations.
Une première peut être sensible aux contrastes
élevés dans une image, une deuxième à
une certaine couleur, une troisième à la
présence de courbes, etc. Les dernières
couches seront enfin sensibles aux combinaisons
entre les caractéristiques précédentes.
L’ordinateur sera ainsi capable de reconnaître
et de traiter des données très complexes.
Mais là où le « deep-learning » est particulièrement
intéressant, c’est qu’au lieu de laisser
aux humains le soin de programmer les bons
critères sur lesquels l’ordinateur doit
s’appuyer pour accomplir sa tâche, on peut
aujourd’hui faire en sorte que l’ordinateur
détermine lui-même les critères pertinents,
et ainsi éviter les biais d’analyse. Par
exemple, si vous apprenez à votre ordinateur
à reconnaître une photo d’éléphant en
lui disant qu’il doit chercher un machin
fripé avec de grandes oreilles, vous risquez
de vous retrouver avec des imprévus
Le « deep-learning » consiste
plutôt à donner à votre logiciel des milliers
de photos avec et sans éléphants, et à
le laisser déterminer la meilleure manière
de les reconnaître. AU-TO-NO-MIE on a dit.
Cette méthode a déjà donné des résultats
spectaculaires. En 2015 le logiciel de jeu
de go AlphaGo, a popularisé le « deep-learning
» auprès du grand public, et c’est sans
doute à cette occasion-là que vous en avez
entendu parler. Contrairement au jeu d’échecs,
les programmeurs avaient beaucoup de mal à
apprendre à un ordinateur à jouer au go,
un jeu très ancien originaire de Chine. Avant
2015, aucun programme informatique n’avait
encore battu de joueurs professionnels alors
que cet exploit a été réalisé dès 1997
pour les échecs par les logiciels d’IBM.
Contrairement à IBM, l’entreprise britannique
DeepMind, a conçu un logiciel qui s’est
perfectionné en partant de zéro et en jouant
au go contre lui-même. Les concepteurs du
logiciel ne lui ont appris que les règles
du jeu, c’est tout. C’est en analysant
ses propres parties et les milliers de variantes
possibles selon la méthode du « deep-learning
» qu’AlphaGo a enfin pu écraser les plus
grands champions humains. En quelques mois,
plus personne ne pouvait rivaliser avec le
logiciel.
On le voit, l’intelligence artificielle,
à travers le « deep-learning », permet
non seulement de traiter des données très
rapidement, mais surtout de déterminer elle-même
la bonne méthode pour résoudre le problème
qu’on lui pose, avec une efficacité totalement
inédite. Cela ouvre dans tous les champs
de recherche des possibilités phénoménales,
et les archéologues, bien sûr, n’ont pas
laissé passer cette chance.
Parmi les premières applications de cette
intelligence artificielle, il y a la reconnaissance
automatisée des vestiges. Avec le projet
ArchAIDE, ces fameux réseaux artificiels
de neurones ont été utilisés dès 2016
par les archéologues pour reconstituer automatiquement
la forme des poteries à partir de simples
fragments. En constituant un corpus de poteries
scannées en 3D, les chercheurs ont livré
à l’ordinateur une immense base de données
dans laquelle il pouvait chercher des critères
communs et ainsi identifier rapidement les
nouveaux tessons de poterie.
Dans les années qui ont suivi, ces compétences
ont aussi été utilisées pour reconnaître
les amphores dans les photographies de prospections
sous-marines, pour
trier de la poterie à partir de sa texture
ou encore pour identifier à
coup sûr les traces de coupe sur les ossements
Ces méthodes permettent
d’analyser des données à une vitesse inégalée
et ainsi d’épargner aux chercheurs des
milliers d’heures de traitement d’images.
Grâce au deep-learning, les archéologues
de l’université de Rennes ont ainsi pu
traiter des centaines de milliers d’images
LIDAR, un laser qui passe à travers le couvert
forestier, pour détecter des cairns néolithiques
dans le Morbihan
Bien plus loin de nous, dans les steppes d’Asie
centrale, ce traitement automatisé appliqué
aux photos satellites a permis de repérer
des dizaines de nouvelles tombes de la culture
Saka, datant entre le VIIe et le IIIe siècle
avant J.-C. Publiée en 2019 dans le Journal
of Archaeological Science, cette étude montre
qu’en cherchant des éléments assez simples,
en l'occurrence des tombes circulaires, l’assistance
de l’intelligence artificielle permet de
faire gagner un temps considérable. La prospection
d’une zone si vaste et si peu peuplée aurait
demandé des années avec les techniques habituelles.
Vous l’avez compris, les applications sont
presque illimitées dans le domaine de la
reconnaissance automatisée. Non seulement
aucun chercheur ne peut rivaliser avec la
vitesse de calcul d’un ordinateur, mais
en plus le logiciel a tendance à moins se
tromper. Les archéologues s’en sont rendu
compte dans la reconnaissance du sexe des
squelettes. Cette analyse, qui est faite d’après
des critères théoriquement objectifs, se
révèle parfois biaisée quand elle est réalisée
par l’œil humain. Les chercheurs peuvent
parfois surinterpréter certains aspects anatomiques,
ce qui trompe leur jugement. Un défaut que
n’ont pas ces logiciels, froids et imperturbables
en toutes circonstances. L’étude publiée
en 2019 dans le Journal of Forensic and Legal
Medicine l’a bien montré.
Avec le deep-learning apparaît même l’espoir
de percer le mystère de certaines écritures
toujours non-déchiffrées. C’est le cas
de la mystérieuse écriture de la vallée
de l’Indus dont on avait parlé dans une
précédente vidéo. Deux chercheurs indiens
ont ainsi initié un programme en 2017 pour
essayer de résoudre cette énigme. Pour l’instant on est
loin de propositions de traductions, il s’agit
surtout de classer les inscriptions et de
les reconnaître de manière automatisée,
mais cela conduira peut-être à des progrès
significatifs dans les années qui viennent.
D’ailleurs, c’est peut-être dans le domaine
des écritures anciennes que l’intelligence
artificielle a le plus à apporter. Dans un
article paru cette année, en mars 2022, une
équipe internationale de chercheurs présente
le dernier né des logiciels intelligents,
appliqué à l’épigraphie.
L’épigraphie, c’est l’étude des textes
anciens, une discipline qui déchiffre les
inscriptions et tente d’en donner la meilleure
traduction possible. Ces textes sont inscrits
sur les supports durs tels que la pierre ou
le métal (Tables Claudiennes), mais cela
ne garantit pas forcément une conservation
idéale. Les épigraphistes doivent donc non
seulement avoir une excellente connaissance
des langues anciennes et de leurs évolutions,
mais aussi être capables de combler les manques
de certains textes abîmés pour en reconstituer
le message originel.
Pour cela, des compilations d’inscriptions
sont régulièrement publiées et constituent
un immense corpus dans lequel aller piocher
des comparaisons. Stockés dans les bibliothèques
d’archéologie, ce sont des livres que le
grand public n’ouvre jamais, ce sont les
matériaux bruts de la recherche. Aujourd’hui,
heureusement pour les chercheurs, certains
de ces corpus sont accessibles en ligne via
des portails de revues ou des sites spécialisés.
Les épigraphistes sont donc des personnes
habituées à ingurgiter de nombreux textes,
dédicaces de monuments, épitaphes et fragments
de discours, pour se constituer une base de
données personnelle. C’est donc avant tout
dans leurs connaissances et dans les références
dont ils ont entendu parler qu’ils piochent
pour interpréter les nouveaux textes. Mais
l’érudition et la mémoire humaine ont
leurs limites.
Et c’est là bien entendu qu’intervient
l’intelligence artificielle. Dans cet article
collectif publié dans la revue Nature, est
présenté un nouvel outil et son énorme
potentiel. Baptisé Ithaca, il se concentre
pour l’instant sur les inscriptions en langue
grecque et se veut capable de restaurer les
éléments manquants ainsi que d’attribuer
une origine géographique et même une datation
aux textes, ce qui est particulièrement utile
sur ces supports où la datation au carbone
14 est inopérante. Les performances de cet
outil sont déjà remarquables puisqu’il
permet de restaurer avec une précision de
62 % les lacunes d’un texte, de les dater
à 30 ans près et atteint même 71 % d’exactitude
sur l’origine géographique.
Ithaca est un outil gratuit qui fonctionne
grâce aux efforts faits depuis des années
pour numériser de très nombreux textes et
mutualiser la recherche. Le logiciel a pu
étudier plus de 78 000 inscriptions et c’est
grâce à ce répertoire d’origine qu’il
peut ensuite extrapoler et interpréter les
nouveaux textes qu’on lui présente. Ithaca
est donc capable de proposer une liste de
mots manquants, une région d’origine, et
une datation, selon leurs plus grandes probabilités
respectives. La présentation synthétique
des résultats sous forme de graphique et
de carte est aussi conçue pour faciliter
la lisibilité des résultats
C’est donc un complément précieux à ce
que les auteurs de l’article appellent le
« répertoire mnémonique » des chercheurs,
autrement dit, leur mémoire et leur capacité
d’analyse. Il n’est pas pour l’instant
question de remplacer les chercheurs. Le logiciel
seul n’est pas en mesure de livrer des interprétations
complexes, il s’agit plutôt d’un genre
de « super-assistant » qui peut opérer
un tri ultra-rapide. Ithaca devrait donc permettre
de mieux comprendre l’histoire grecque dans
les années à venir.
Les développements futurs de l’intelligence
artificielle en archéologie sont incertains.
Qui sait ce qu’elle sera capable d’accomplir
demain. Pour l’instant, il s’agit surtout
d’identifier plus vite que les humains,
de les aider dans le traitement des données.
Il est probable que dans les prochaines décennies,
les programmes intelligents pourront aller
toujours plus loin dans l’interprétation
: reconstituer des textes toujours plus fragmentaires,
reconnaître des morceaux d’objets toujours
plus petits…
En 2020, Shawn Graham, qui est professeur
à l’université de Carleton au Canada,
a publié un livre intitulé An Enchantment
of Digital Archaeology, dans lequel il postule
que ces nouvelles technologies pourront pratiquement
« ramener à la vie » les sociétés du
passé. La notion « d’enchantement » qu’il
utilise est donc à entendre comme une émotion
mais à la fois comme une forme de magie.
Il s’agit de réanimer les morts en faisant
parler les artefacts, les archéologues devenant
en quelque sorte des apprentis nécromanciens.
Graham pense qu’en nourrissant un logiciel
de l’intégralité des écrits de Cicéron
par exemple, on pourra bientôt créer une
émulation de ce personnage historique et
le faire parler. En donnant au logiciel des
informations sur les conditions de vie, les
croyances, le climat, etc., on peut même
imaginer obtenir une personnalité virtuelle
complexe et crédible. Donnez à manger les
Commentaires sur la guerre des Gaules à votre
ordinateur, et il vous sortira bientôt un
Jules César avec qui discuter.
Bien entendu cette simulation n’aura pas
grand-chose à voir avec la réalité du passé,
ce sera un modèle simplifié, un « mort-vivant
» encore primitif, mais Graham ne doute pas
qu’ils seront de plus en plus complexes
avec le perfectionnement de ces techniques.
Cette « nécromancie digitale » a des intérêts
pour la recherche, mais aussi des applications
déroutantes qui ont déjà pu être explorées
par la science-fiction, dans Black Mirror
par exemple.
Si le monde des sciences humaines et celui
des sciences informatiques ne communiquent
souvent pas beaucoup, une plus grande collaboration
semble indispensable. Les idées les plus
stimulantes viennent très souvent de l’association
de plusieurs points de vue, l’archéologie
l’a montré depuis très longtemps en associant
des architectes, des artisans, des ingénieurs,
des ethnologues, des médecins ou des botanistes
pour exploiter les données issues des fouilles.
Les ressources de l’intelligence artificielle
sont sans doute le prochain défi qui s’offre
aux archéologues.
avec quel personnage historique aimeriez-vous
discuter ?
Vous pouvez retrouver les sources de tous
les articles utilisés pour réaliser cette
vidéo dans la barre
de description.